- [Instructor] All across ecosystems,
we know that organisms
interact in specific ways
and scientists use special words
to describe these types of interaction,
competition, predation and mutualism.
So let's first talk about competition
which we have already talked
about in other videos.
In this picture here,
do you see competition?
Pause this video and think about that.
Well, one limited resource
that these animals need
to survive is water.
There's only a limited
amount in this watering hole
over here and so you could
imagine there is competition
not just amongst the
members of a population
let's say between the zebra
but also between members
of different species,
between different
populations in a community.
The zebras are not just competing
for water with each other
but also with these antelope
or with these buffalo over here.
There might also be competition for food.
It doesn't seem like there's
a lot of grass to eat
for all of these animals
that like to graze on grass.
So now let's move on to predation.
Predation is when one
organism eats another organism
usually to its own benefit.
Do you see any predation happening here?
Well, we don't see any of these animals
chasing and killing each other.
There might be other
animals like lions offscreen
that might hunt and kill
and eat these animals
right over here
but we know that these
animals do eat grass
and as I said, it's not just about hunting
and killing and eating
from one animal to another.
It could be one organism to another.
So the eating of the
grass by these animals
could actually be considered
a form of predation
especially if it kills the grass.
A more obvious form of predation
is this brown bear here
that has gotten the
salmon out of this river.
It is clearly hunting and killing
the salmon for its benefit
and it is likely that each of these bears
are in competition with other bears
for this limited resource.
So last but not least,
let's think a little bit about mutualism.
Mutualism happens when
two organisms benefit
from interacting with each other.
Right over here, we have these starlings
that actually hang out on this buffalo
and pick lice and ticks
off the buffalo's fur.
This is mutualism because
both parties benefit.
The starlings are able to get food
and the buffalo no longer
have these parasites,
these things that are
living off of the buffalo
sucking its blood out of its body
and also probably not itching as much.
Now, based on how I just described it,
there's not just mutualism here.
There's also predation
because these birds are actually hunting
and killing the lice and the
ticks on the buffalo's body.
Now, related to being a
predator is another word
known as being a parasite
and that's what the lice
and the ticks are doing
where they're sucking
the blood of the buffalo
but they're not considered predators.
They're more parasites because
they don't kill the buffalo.
They're just taking some
resources away from it.
So I'll leave you there.
I encourage you when you look at nature,
when you go to a park next time,
when you go watch a documentary,
I encourage you to think
about how competition,
predation and mutualism is
happening in an ecosystem
that you are seeing or
that you're a part of.